guest lectures are an important part of  visualized in Japan the residential  course each time I teach it I have  professor John tower a guest lecturer at  least once sometimes twice so I also  invite dr. Ellen Sebring who is a  specialist on visual culture and history  and to prepare for these guest lectures  I asked the guest lectures to give me  some assignment to give the students in  the case of Professor John dollar he  gave me series of questions about the  MOOC content what did they think about  this what did they think about this  how'd they improve the MOOC and the  students wrote like a single page  single-spaced and I gave that to  professor darrall ahead of time and he  read it and I think he spent almost half  the class talking about what the  students wrote now these students are  very very engaged with the class